ELEANOR CARMELI: Hi, everyone.
My names' Eleanor Carmeli.
And I'd like to welcome you
to the Google Hanukkah party
here at the Google
New York office,
on behalf of the Zagat
team, team Jewglers New
York, and TalksAtGoogle.
So welcome.
Happy Hanukkah.
Happy holidays to everyone.
And without further
ado, I'm going
to bring on Kelly Dobkin who's
a senior editor on the Zagat
team.
And she's going to
take away the show,
and bring on our famous,
well-known, and fantastically
inspired chefs.
So, Kelly.
[APPLAUSE]
KELLY DOBKIN: Thank you.
Happy Hanukkah, everyone.
We're super excited.
I am particularly excited to
have two of my favorite shops
in York participating
in this latke cookoff.
So many of you may have
heard of Mile End Deli.
We have Chef Eli Sussman.
And we also have Chef
Einat Admony from Taim,
Balaboosta, and the
recently opened Bar Bolonat.
So without further
ado, we're going
to have both chefs show you
how to make some awesome latkes
today, two very
different recipes.
After the demos, you guys
can ask questions during
and immediately upon finishing.
And then we're also going
to have-- each latke will
be available on either side.
So you guys can taste them
and vote on the winner.
We're going to tell you more
about that in a few minutes.
But first, let me bring up Eli
Sussman from Mile End Deli.
[APPLAUSE]
Hey.
How are you?
ELI SUSSMAN: How's it going?
KELLY DOBKIN: Good.
ELI SUSSMAN: Thanks
for having me.
KELLY DOBKIN: Yeah.
So walk us through this recipe.
This is a very creative
twist on-- Mile End
does some pretty classic
latkes in the restaurant
and for catering
during Hanukkah.
So this recipe, Eli, is
kind of inspired by a bagel.
Tell me a little about--
ELI SUSSMAN: Yes.
So Mile End is a Montreal-style
Jewish delicatessen.
It was started by two
guys from Montreal.
And there's a restaurant
there called Beautys.
And they do a bagel
sandwich call a Beauty.
And it is.
If you've ever been to
Mile End, The Beauty
is a bagel with lox, and
cream cheese, and capers,
and tomatoes, and onions.
So I'm doing a
Beauty latke today.
KELLY DOBKIN: Awesome.
ELI SUSSMAN: It's going to be a
classic latke based on my dad's
recipe, super, super simple.
And then it's going
to be topped with lox,
cream cheese, some very
thinly shaved shallots,
fried capers, cherry tomatoes,
a little bit of chive.
KELLY DOBKIN: Wow.
That sounds amazing.
I'm really excited.
OK.
So let's get started.
What is the very first step
to making these latkes?
ELI SUSSMAN: Yeah.
So the very first step is
probably the most boring step
to watch.
But so I'm just going
to grate the potatoes.
So the reason that you
grate the potatoes-- these
have been washed.
And the reason that I'm going
to grate them into water
is because potatoes
oxidize super quickly,
and they turn brown.
So at the restaurant, we
do this in huge quantities.
And we don't use
a home box grater.
But here, this is
what I'm going to use.
KELLY DOBKIN: See latkes
were the first thing
I learned to make.
And I was always forced
to hand grate them.
My dad said you had
But do you agree?
Does it make a huge
difference or--
ELI SUSSMAN: I suppose.
We look at this way
at the restaurants.
It's like, sometimes
things that take longer,
you put a little more
love and care into them,
and they come out better.
A lot of things that
we do at the restaurant
are the fashioned way, which
is kind of we pride ourselves
on doing things,
reinventing, and re-imagining
the deli classic.
So a lot of the stuff that we
do takes a little bit longer.
And often that results
in it being better.
KELLY DOBKIN: Yeah.
ELI SUSSMAN: So no.
You don't need to
hand grate them.
But I figure that
a lot of people
don't have Cuisinarts or
whatever at their apartment,
so-- probably most of you don't
even cook in your apartments.
KELLY DOBKIN:
Probably most people
don't have the counter
space to even get--
ELI SUSSMAN: Really,
really clean kitchens
that no one has ever touched
in there entire lives.
KELLY DOBKIN: Yeah.
ELI SUSSMAN: So yeah.
At the restaurant, we dd--
well, right now for Hanukkah,
we're doing 50-pound batches
of potatoes for latkes.
So we don't do those by hand.
We do them in a [? robaku. ?]
KELLY DOBKIN: That
would take like a week.
Yeah.
ELI SUSSMAN: They still
get formed by hand.
So last night-- we had two
really big parties today.
So we made 1,000 latkes last
night for this party as well.
And they're all hand-formed.
So it's still time
consuming no matter what.
KELLY DOBKIN: So tell
me a little bit about
your-- you're saying this is--
ELI SUSSMAN: Joel do you want to
come up and grate a little bit?
KELLY DOBKIN: I can help too.
ELI SUSSMAN: This
is my favorite part.
I get to put my boss to work.
Joe's one of the
owners of Mile End.
And I'm going to give him
the incredibly tedious task
of creating the potatoes.
You want to slide over
just a little bit?
KELLY DOBKIN: So
Joel, have you ever
had to grate any latkes before?
JOEL TIETOLMAN: Not
since high school.
[LAUGHTER]
KELLY DOBKIN: And how long can
you grate for is the question.
Like, 5 minutes, 10 minutes?
What's your--
ELI SUSSMAN: He's already bored.
JOEL TIETOLMAN: It;s almost
the same motion as slicing
briskets.
So it's not that far off.
I'll be good.
ELI SUSSMAN: So
the next step is--
so you're going to grate
the onions as well.
And what I did was I
just took one end off.
And then I made a slight
slit down the side.
And I"m going to peel
off the outer layer.
And what I want to do is I want
to leave the nub on because you
want to make sure that
you leave something
to hold the onion together when
you're going to be grating it.
If you take off both ends, the
onion's going to split apart.
That's ready for Joel to
go grate that in a couple.
JOEL TIETOLMAN: And do
the [INAUDIBLE] also?
ELI SUSSMAN: No.
When we're done
with the potatoes.
That one, you can hang
on that for a second.
So this recipe is super simple.
It's just really potato,
onion, four, matzo meal, egg,
and a little bit
of salt and pepper.
And we do a lot of
zany, fun latkes.
We do sweet potato latkes.
We do butternut squash latkes.
We do beet latkes.
I like this one because
as like a classic base,
who doesn't like fried potato?
KELLY DOBKIN: No one I know.
ELI SUSSMAN: As a pretty much
a base for any type of topping,
we go with the classic latke.
KELLY DOBKIN: Is
this pretty close
so like what your father taught
you as a kid growing up or--
ELI SUSSMAN: So this is
exactly my dad's recipe,
just with a little bit
of matzo meal thrown in.
I like the matzo meal
because texturally,
I think it's nice on the inside.
And also, even though
we're grating the potatoes
into water, obviously, when
you're frying something,
moisture is the enemy, right?
So I guess it's slightly
counter intuitive.
But so we're going to
grate all these into water.
And then we're
going to squeeze out
all the water, which
is kind of messy,
but also part of
the fun I think.
When you make latkes,
you make them by hand.
It's a little bit sloppy.
You're trying to probably
do it with your friends
or with your family.
And so when Joel grates
all the potatoes,
I'll hand squeeze all
of the moisture out.
KELLY DOBKIN: He's still going.
JOEL TIETOLMAN: Almost done.
ELI SUSSMAN: And then
we'll grate the onions,
squeeze out the moisture
from the onions,
and then mix in the
dry ingredients,
and then put an egg in,
and form them together.
So I'll get this
started right now.
KELLY DOBKIN: Great.
So would you say--
what would you
say are the most
common, when you
experience a bad latke, what
are some of the characteristics?
Are they overcooked,
undercooked?
Are people not squeezing
out enough water
before they fry them?
What do you think are the--
ELI SUSSMAN: Hold on.
Is their a pilot on this?
There it is.
Got it.
Cool.
Sorry.
What was the question?
KELLY DOBKIN: What
do you think are
some of the most
common-- I see latkes
botched all the
time in restaurants.
Sometimes they're soggy.
Sometimes they're overcooked.
What do you think are like--
what's a common mistake when
making latkes, Do you think?
ELI SUSSMAN: Well, we par
fry ours and then re-fry them
to order.
And so that's just
something that we
do with our french fries.
It's something that a
lot of restaurants do.
And so we fry them
at 250 degrees.
And then we re-fry
them before they
hit the table at 350 degrees.
And we found that that
makes them super crispy.
I imagine that if
you're at home,
you probably don't
want to double fry.
It's jut kind of-- it's
an annoying process.
So you could just fry to order.
I also think making
them really skinny
is good, because the less
interior, the more surface
area.
You're going to get
a crispier latke.
But also, it's really about just
doing them in a timely manner.
You don't want them
to sit out very long.
So I guess if you do them, you
could hold them in your oven
at like 200 degrees
for two hours
or something like that
after you fry them.
But they're obviously the
best when they're made
and them served right away.
KELLY DOBKIN: While we're
getting stuff ready,
does anyone have any latke
questions they want to ask Eli?
Now's your chance.
ELI SUSSMAN: Or any
other questions?
KELLY DOBKIN: Or any other
questions about Mile End or--
ELI SUSSMAN: I'll talk
about latkes all day
if you really want.
So yeah.
So I'm just going to
squeeze out as much moisture
as I can from this.
ELEANOR CARMELI: That's
a super important step
is squeezing out the water,
because if anyone else at home
is trying to fry a potato
without doing that,
it just doesn't get brown.
ELI SUSSMAN: There
are other ways
to guard against oxidation.
But this is just like
the old-fashioned way.
We can do it like this
and it works out fine.
You can, definitely.
If you're doing
a huge batch, you
could grate the potatoes
several hours in advance
and hold them in the water.
They don't really
deteriorate that much.
So if you can't
afford time to do it
all in one day or whatever,
you can do them the day before,
for all the people that are
having huge latke parties
at your apartment later today.
KELLY DOBKIN: Oh.
AUDIENCE: So you cooked
1,000 latkes last night?
ELI SUSSMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How many people
does it take to do that?
How do you stage the potatoes?
ELI SUSSMAN: How do we what?
AUDIENCE: How do you
stage the potatoes?
Do you put them in a
gigantic pool of water?
ELI SUSSMAN: So we do them
in like 30-pound batches.
So you sanitize the drop
sink in the kitchen,
you fill it with water, you have
the potatoes sitting in there.
And then those, because we
actually do them so quickly,
we don't grate those into water.
We just alternate
between onion and potato.
And it goes through
the [? robaku ?],
which is like an
industrial cooking device.
And it has a grater that spins.
So we grate it into
a huge, basically
like a plastic bus tub.
And then we mix all the
ingredients into it.
And then three guys
stand In a row.
And we just form them by hand.
And we just throw them into the
fryer and do them in batches.
It's not super difficult
from a labor standpoint.
It's just time consuming,
because you can only
fry 30 at a time.
And they take a couple minutes
to fry every single time.
Yeah.
You can turn it
down a little bit.
KELLY DOBKIN: It's
getting a little smokey.
ELI SUSSMAN: You can turn it
all the way off, actually.
KELLY DOBKIN: One more question?
AUDIENCE: How long does it
take to eat 1,000 latkes?
ELI SUSSMAN: You guys are
going to figure that out.
How long does it take--
KELLY DOBKIN: I think I
could eat 1,000 myself.
So that's very relative.
ELI SUSSMAN: It went to a
bunch of different events
today, because we're well
known as a Jewish restaurant.
So [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] all
Jewish holidays we kind of get
hammered by everybody looking
for us to cater because in New
York, most people don't really
cook themselves, unfortunately.
So we end up doing-- yeah.
We do a lot of latkes on--
JOEL TIETOLMAN: A lot of latkes.
Or like--
ELI SUSSMAN: A lot of doughnuts.
JOEL TIETOLMAN: A
lot of sufganiyah.
ELI SUSSMAN: Yeah.
And then we do a lot of
braised brisket, obviously,
and the classics,
a lot of poutine.
KELLY DOBKIN: So
the next step is
we're going to mix the
dry ingredients, right?
ELI SUSSMAN: Yeah.
We're going to mix
the dry ingredients.
And then here is
my pitcher of veg--
that should be enough oil.
KELLY DOBKIN: Enough
for eight nights.
ELI SUSSMAN: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
So it was great.
It was like very ironic.
Our fryer died yesterday
at our Brooklyn location.
So on the first day of Hanukkah
we had nowhere to fry anything.
So we were doing latkes
in this little baby fryer
off to the side.
So luckily we were able to
get another fryer in there.
But it was--
JOEL TIETOLMAN: It was
a Hanukkah miracle.
ELI SUSSMAN: Yeah.
Exactly.
JOEL TIETOLMAN: In
the middle of lunch
it took us about 45
minuets, which is actually
no time at all to
put out the old fryer
and put in the new one.
It was an adventure.
ELI SUSSMAN: Pretty much
the worst possible timing.
KELLY DOBKIN: So how do
you know like how much?
ELI SUSSMAN: Yeah.
I knew you were
going to ask that.
You were like, how did
you know what to put in?
I'm just going to do it by
feel, honestly, which is--
KELLY DOBKIN: You don't it too
wet, don't want it too dry.
ELI SUSSMAN: I
printed out recipes.
And you guys should
definitely follow that.
But so what I'm looking
for is like a sort
of a tacky consistency.
What I like to say
is like, you can
put an imprint in the latkes and
it doesn't come back upright.
So if the latkes were wet,
if you pushed into it,
they would just kind of spread.
What I'm looking
for is the latke
to be able to hold into a shape.
So if I form it into a ball
like a size of a golf ball,
and I press it all
together, I want
it to have a sort of tackiness
so that it holds, right?
So it's like almost there.
I can feel that it's
pretty much there.
I'm just going to mix
it up a little bit more.
Joel, can you hit me with a
little bit of salt and pepper,
please?
KELLY DOBKIN: I love how
Joel's the sous chef, today.
ELI SUSSMAN: I know, right?
Cool.
KELLY DOBKIN: Do you need
me to put any oil in?
ELI SUSSMAN: Yeah.
Can you get a little
oil going for me?
KELLY DOBKIN: This is
a team effort, guys.
ELI SUSSMAN: And as
you can see, it's
like there's no real clean way
to make latkes with your hands.
So you got it?
KELLY DOBKIN: Yeah.
ELI SUSSMAN: So when my dad
makes latkes at the house--
so they have just like
a normal home kitchen.
Yeah.
Give me about an
inch and a half.
KELLY DOBKIN: OK.
ELI SUSSMAN: Yeah.
That's great.
So you don't want
the lat-- I don't
like to totally submerge
the latkes when I took them
at home.
So just a good rule
of thumb with anything
is like, if you're frying,
it's obviously super dangerous
to be frying at your house.
So you want to be really
careful that you're paying
close attention to the oil.
And also, my dad likes to
line the floor with newspaper
because there's a
lot splattering,
and it gets super
slippery and stuff.
And you want to
use a fish spatula,
because when you're transferring
with all the oil and stuff,
you don't want to
be spilling it.
So don't use a regular
spatula or spoon or something.
KELLY DOBKIN: OK.
Cool.
So while we're starting
to fry up over here,
I'm going to get started
with Einat as well.
So Einat.
EINAT ADMONY: Hi.
KELLY DOBKIN: Hi.
Einat is the chef and owner
of Tain Balaboosta and Bar
Bolonat.
So Einat, we're going to
do a little bit of a twist
on a traditional latke using a
bunch of different vegetables.
Tell me a little
about your recipe.
EINAT ADMONY: All right.
So basically this latke is
made out of potatoes, opah,
sweet potato, carrot, onion.
And then I put some Granny Smith
apples inside, again, mostly
because I personally don't like
the apple sauce with latke.
I never got the point of it.
So I said, you know what?
This is going to go in.
And it's actually
make it really nice.
It gives some tiny
tanginess inside.
Very similar to Eli,
we squeeze everything.
The carrot don't have enough--
KELLY DOBKIN: --moisture.
EINAT ADMONY: --moisture.
So we don't need to do that,
but the potato and the onion.
I also add thyme and
rosemary a little bit.
And we're going
to serve it today
with preserved lemon
yogurt and micro-cilantro.
KELLY DOBKIN: Wow.
That sounds great.
ELEANOR CARMELI: Huh?
You got lost?
KELLY DOBKIN: It's not over yet.
So chef, so you
grew up in Israel.
And I'm always curious.
Were latkes different there?
Were they the same?
EINAT ADMONY: To be honest,
I didn't grow up on latke.
KELLY DOBKIN: OK.
EINAT ADMONY: I know.
KELLY DOBKIN: So for Hanukkah,
did you guys have them,
or not at all?
EINAT ADMONY: A different one.
Latke is a very
Ashkenazi dish that I
used to eat at my
next door neighbor.
My mom do different things.
She do like mostly sweet stuff.
Like we do sufganiyot
from scratch,
which is the Israeli
donuts, if you don't know.
And she do other stuff.
She do funnel cake.
Latke, I started doing
when I came to New York
like 16 years ago,
and I love it.
It's like [? rashty ?], which I
used to work a venue back then.
And they have [? rashty ?].
And I'm like ah.
So it's very similar for me.
KELLY DOBKIN: I've never
had a latke I don't like.
EINAT ADMONY: Really?
KELLY DOBKIN: Well, I've
had some bad latkes.
I know everyone else
probably has too.
EINAT ADMONY: No.
KELLY DOBKIN: But the
general idea of a latke I'm
on board with.
EINAT ADMONY: The only
problem that-- the latke-- I
have a falafel show.
I always upset when
people order to go.
And they always do.
But it's not as--
KELLY DOBKIN: It's not meant.
EINAT ADMONY: I'ts not.
It's you have to
eat it the minute
it's come out of the fryer.
Latke, the same thing.
All the crispiness,
all the texture,
it needs to be
eaten on the spot.
KELLY DOBKIN: Yeah.
So we're just getting
the burner going.
We're mixing all of
the grated ingredients
together, once we
squeeze the water out.
Does anyone have any questions
for Einat while we're here?
No?
EINAT ADMONY: Nothing?
All right.
AUDIENCE: What goes
in your falafel?
It's so good.
EINAT ADMONY: Chick pea, onion,
garlic, cumin, coriander,
black pepper, and salt.
Did that cover it all?
KELLY DOBKIN: There's got to be
a secret ingredient that you're
not--
EINAT ADMONY: And there
is recipe in my cookbook.
So yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
KELLY DOBKIN: Einat was actually
on "Bobby Flay Throwdown,"
I don't know if
you guys saw that.
It was a couple of years
ago, making falafel.
EINAT ADMONY: 10 years ago.
KELLY DOBKIN: 10 years ago.
Feels like yesterday.
Yeah.
EINAT ADMONY: Actually he won.
But then he reversed
the judges--
KELLY DOBKIN: --decision.
EINAT ADMONY: Exactly He came
after the match and said,
you know what?
They don't know what
they're talking about,
which I totally agree.
All right.
ELEANOR CARMELI: Hey,
just wanted to announce.
If anybody has any
questions, we're
going to finish up the cooking
demo in just a few minutes
and let all of you eat the
delicious things that you're
watching them make.
And so if you have any
questions at this point--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Over here.
ELEANOR CARMELI:
They are all fresh.
I promise.
If you have any questions,
just raise your hand
and I'll walk around with a mic.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right there.
AUDIENCE: Where can we
get a free [INAUDIBLE]?
[LAUGHTER]
KELLY DOBKIN: Guys?
EINAT ADMONY: Wow.
Good question.
ELI SUSSMAN: Free?
EINAT ADMONY: Yeah.
ELEANOR CARMELI: Back
here, just one moment.
KELLY DOBKIN: Maybe you'll
get one for Hanukkah.
You never know.
ELI SUSSMAN: Talk to Google.
Maybe they'll--
EINAT ADMONY: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: So I'm curious.
Of each of the chefs, what
are your favorite condiments
for latkes?
Or, what do you consider
acceptable condiments
for latke?
EINAT ADMONY: Not applesauce.
ELI SUSSMAN: Yeah, I
honestly, I didn't like
apple sauce growing up either.
And I don't really
like sour cream.
I am the most sacrilegious.
I like to eat them like
they're hash browns.
I like to dip them in ketchup.
EINAT ADMONY: Ketchup?
ELI SUSSMAN: Sorry.
KELLY DOBKIN: Sounds
good, actually.
[LAUGHTER]
ELI SUSSMAN: I'm
from the suburbs.
I'm from the train.
Like, they're basically
Jewish hashbrowns.
So for when it comes to
actual true toppings,
I'm not really a sweet guy ever.
EINAT ADMONY: You're not?
ELI SUSSMAN: I
like savory stuff.
EINAT ADMONY: You
look very sweet.
ELI SUSSMAN: Oh, thank you.
ELEANOR CARMELI: All right.
We have a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Neither one of you
mentioned what kind of oil
you like to use and what kind
of oil you don't like to use.
EINAT ADMONY: Not olive oil.
ELI SUSSMAN: Yeah.
EINAT ADMONY: Not blend oil.
Canola will be the best for me.
ELI SUSSMAN: Yeah.
Same.
KELLY DOBKIN: So in
the frying process,
I've never really
figured this out.
How do you know when
a latke is done?
Just by looking at it?
ELI SUSSMAN: Well, the
great thing about a latke
is there's a lot of
margin for error,
because it's fried potato.
And pretty much, it's going to
be good no matter what as long
as you put salt on it.
So I'm looking for
a deep golden brown.
So you could say the
thinnest that I made them,
it's like maybe three
minutes each side
depending on how
hot your oil is.
But I'll just hold
one up right now.
So you guys can see.
KELLY DOBKIN: That
looked very pretty.
ELI SUSSMAN: So that's
what I'm looking
for in terms of brownness.
And then I'm just going
to do the other side
to the same level.
And then I'm going
to put salt on them.
ELEANOR CARMELI: We're
going to take two more
questions from the audience.
And then we'll ask our chefs
to stand by their latkes
and start serving.
So one more question over here.
ELI SUSSMAN: The latkes
are all the way over there.
AUDIENCE: Do your recipes
change from year to year,
or are they constant over time?
ELI SUSSMAN: Do
the recipes change?
AUDIENCE: Change
from year to year,
or do you use the same one?
ELI SUSSMAN: The latke
recipe hasn't really changed.
Yeah.
KELLY DOBKIN: Right.
OK.
And we have our final
audience question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I was
actually wondering
who won when you went
up against Bobby Flay.
EINAT ADMONY: Where was that?
Hi.
Yeah.
What's the question?
AUDIENCE: When you were on
"Throwndown with Bobby Flay,"
who won the competition?
EINAT ADMONY: So I just say.
Somebody asked that.
AUDIENCE: Oops.
Sorry about that.
EINAT ADMONY: But
Bobby Flay won.
But-- it was a very
upsetting moment.
No.
We changed it.
AUDIENCE: He cheated.
EINAT ADMONY: No.
No.
His falafel wasn't as good.
But the judges wasn't
as good as well.
[LAUGHTER]
They really didn't know anything
about middle eastern food.
They said that my
food was SoHo-chic
and his looking
like traditional,
which was very funny.
But months after,
Bobby Flay came
to Taim, the small Taim in the
Village, with all his crew.
And he changed the
decision of the judges.
So that was a really nice
and genuine thing to do.
AUDIENCE: So you won.
EINAT ADMONY: Huh
ELI SUSSMAN: She won.
EINAT ADMONY:
Everybody thinks I won.
But it's not true.
And I'm an honest person.
No.
I didn't.
AUDIENCE: Well,
she's here today.
And Bobby Flay's not.
So thank you.
ELI SUSSMAN: My latkes are done.
ELEANOR CARMELI: All right.
All right.
KELLY DOBKIN: OK.
Do we want any final
comments from the chefs,
anymore advice for the audience,
thoughts for the holiday,
dos and don'ts in
your kitchen at home?
ELI SUSSMAN: Dos and don'ts
for the entire kitchen?
No.
I hope everyone has a
really nice Hanukkah.
I hope you enjoy the latkes.
The latkes that you're
having are just like these,
but obviously, they were
fried a little bit ago.
So you won't be getting the
exact same fresh out-of-the-oil
crispiness.
But I really hope
you enjoy them.
And we're over here.
And she's over there.
So please come.
And we'd love to start
feeding you guys now.
KELLY DOBKIN: Yes.
And once you guys
taste the latkes,
there's going to
be a voting system.
Eleanor's going to explain.
But it's pretty simple.
It just goes on back there.
Yeah.
So we're going to get
the latkes rolling out.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you so much--
ELEANOR CARMELI:
Round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]